[Musique]
vous êtes jolie en jambes et bien après
avoir passé 30 années dans les forces
armées canadiennes
j'en retire un profond sentiment
d'humilité mais aussi beaucoup de
culpabilité pour ne pas avoir été en
mesure de supporter davantage les
populations dans le besoin que j'ai
rencontré mais avant de m'entretenir
avec vous le capitaine grégoire va se
transformer en louis et je vais vous
parler en tant qu' en tant que civil que
je suis aujourd'hui
au moins tu as fais donc mon dernier
déploiement en afghanistan en date de
mars 2009 a été une expérience
inoubliable
j'ai eu la chance d'agir comme coach
pour une compagnie d'infanterie afghane
composée de soixante et dix hommes
cette expérience a été tout à fait
semblable à celle qui avait été
effectuée en 1916 1918 par un officier
de liaison britannique qui avait mené la
révolte arabe
cet officier de liaison britannique dont
les stratégies et les tactiques sont
toujours enseigné dans certains collèges
militaire avait été interprété par
l'acteur peter o'toole dans le film
lawrence d'arabie de 1960 et 2 pour ceux
qui ont des cheveux blancs comme moi
gris blanc s'en souviennent ce film
avait remporté avait rapporté cet as car
aujourd'hui je suis pas ici pour faire
renaître car bien entendu je veux
partager avec vous pour les prochaines
minutes
l'ouverture d'esprit que cette
incroyable peuple afghan meuh meuh
transmis rapidement sur la photo vous
voyez une base opérationnelle avancée
c'était ma base opérationnelle avancée
situé dans le plan de jouer en
afghanistan devraient de la rivière
arghandab ce cette base ne mesurais
seulement 150 m par 200 250 mètres et
nous étions huit canadiens avec nos
soixante et dix soldats afghans et on
vivait en harmonie
eh bien il ya des temps au québec qui
sont faciles à réaliser
mais à l'afghanistan c'est pratiquement
impossible ou très très difficile je
prends pour exemple aller distribuer des
fournitures scolaires dans une école
dont on écoles en fait le tout près de
mon piquant et cette expérience cette
opération l'autre demander tous les
effectifs de la compagnie fallait se
déplacer vers la petite école et former
un périmètre de sécurité de 300 m je
vais vous visualisez avant de rentrer à
l'école avant de se rendre à l'école
avait soixante soixante personnes qui
font un périmètre de 300 mètres pour
nous protéger pour les quelques instants
qu'on avait à remettre des fournitures
scolaires ou professeurs et attention à
ne pas apporter des crayon et du papier
avec le logo canada pour ne pas que le
pauvre professeur surface menacé de mort
encore une fois par les insurgés qui
circulait dans le secteur
on parle souvent québec des conditions
routières des problèmes de transport on
parle des nids-de-poule qui font les
premières pages dans les journaux
printemps est bien en afghanistan votre
vote auto peu rendez-vous complet dans
un nid de poule
croyez-le ou non
plusieurs routes sont encore miné et
encore des engins explosifs sous le soul
soudas soit quelques de là soit bien
entendu et sa force
les populations les pauvres personnes
qui ont des véhicules y en a beaucoup à
se faire à se construire des chemins
parallèles des routes parallèles pour
éviter des dangers dans mon secteur à
moi et bien dans les gens circulaient
fréquemment dans le lit de la rivière
arghandab pour éviter ces dangers
j'ai effectué bien entendu beaucoup de
beaucoup de patrouille et d'opérations
dans le pain de jouer et j'ai porté
souvent tension denrées alimentaires qui
est en vente dans les bazars et je peux
vous confirmer s'était nettement
suffisant dans mon fétiche base hors
également il y avait une pharmacie qui
n'emportaient que le nom et par respect
au musée du maine j'en ai pas être en
mesure
la prendre en photo j'ai pris beaucoup
de photos mais pas ma pharmacie sur des
tablettes grâce à eux ils s'alignaient
des bocaux des flat ont des racines
d'armes ou de plantes des pièces de
motos usagers et bien entendu des cartes
d'appel l'air qu'on respire en
afghanistan est assez malsaine
d'ailleurs en 2004 alors que j'étais à
kaboul nous avions en fait les
techniciens médicaux avait fait faire
des tests et le taux de matière fécale
était incroyablement élevé je peux vous
confirmer que ne vous ne pouvez pas et
dans une personne de 40 ans rappelle le
double ici au canada dès janvier huit
viviers east très vite et je parle aussi
de la malnutrition temps leur est bien
on voit souvent dans des zambiens distri
horizontaux dans leurs dents qui
rappelle cette malnutrition
le cadeau précieux de l'eau potable
prend tout son sens en afghanistan dans
ce pays semi désertique où les
températures vont dépenser les plus 40
celsius en plein mois de juillet l'eau
est aussi que l'eau est pompée les
tâches minina des ruisseaux qui porte le
nom de wadi et elle sera tendue vers
sciemment par des fermiers qu'ils
l'attendent qui vont en fait là séparés
par leurs pétales dont les fermiers ont
des lions div
il ya des plages en race si on peut dire
et ils vont même usé de violence pour
s'approprier de cette eau
j'avais des photos mais je les envie pas
amené de sa vie alors j'en avais en mars
les enfants 1 vont aller bien entendu de
la fusée plusieurs fois par jour dans
des contenants de l'huile végétale
recyclée et puis ils vont la porte à la
maison pour la cuisine ou pour pour la
laisser bien entendu et on boit pas
d'eau froide en afghanistan la seule eau
la seule eau qui peut être rafraîchi et
mises dans des dents des enfants dans
des cruches en terre cuite qu'il allait
se faire coller vers l'extérieur c'est
un vieux truc de la mésopotamie donc pas
froide métrage est de retour dans les
grandes villes comme kandahar vous
n'êtes pas sûr non plus de voir couler
le précieux liquide
en tournant la poignée du robinet parce
que tout comme dans les champs
au loup est ce nom n'aura pas rétabli et
dirigés vers les différents quartiers
les afghanes n'ont jamais eu le cadeau
de la paix depuis des milliers d'années
impossible les jours de congé le jour de
congé qui s'appuyer le vendredi ici qui
s'appelle du mans en afghanistan est
possible de faire ses emplettes dans un
bazar sans crainte d'être victimes d'un
attentat terroriste
l'atmosphère est oppressante c'est très
pesant déjà se déplace comme design des
animaux traquer le regard furtif
les déplacements sont rapides ici et
dont vous vois déjà amputé encore qui
nous rappelle de toute cette violence
qui tente de se frayer un chemin dans
cette masse grouillante et puis derrière
certains postes de police on retrouve
encore des amas de tôles rouillées
noirci qui qui était qui étaient en fait
des véhicules piégés qui ont fait leur
oeuvre destructrice et nous les soldats
canadiens comment s'en sort dans toute
cette violence
eh bien nous nous déshumanise on nous
nous déshumanise on nous oublions qui on
est nous oublions demain nous oublions
nos projets nous oublions notre corps
notre famille nous avons à garder le
focus absolument sur la mission
nous développons une hypervigilance unis
pensent vigilance qui m'a sauvé la vie
plusieurs fois en afghanistan mais qui
détruit ma vie au canada et on commet
des actes disproportionnée face à cette
violence au lieu de cogner à une porte
pour aller parler avec les gens voient
la défoncer on va tirer sur rv à faire
feu sur des sur des jacks sur des
gardiens à armée qui protège les
travailleurs de la voirie le pauvre
fermier qui va se faire prendre
avec une jerry khan de diesel va se
faire immédiatement accusé d'être un
terroriste qui fabriquent des bombes
artisanales parce que le diesel sert à
faire des explosifs la barre mon dieu on
voit se créer des ennemis imaginaires va
faire feu sur des ennemis qui n'existe
ce pas on va recouvrer nos déplacements
à pied qui sont sans danger parce que
souvent on n'est pas nécessairement en
contact avec l'ennemi et on va couvrir
que des obus fumigènes de l'artillerie
pratiquement sert absolument à rien et
que dire de nos convois qui fait le trop
souvent viva le et qui ajoute un stress
supplémentaire à tout ce chaos que ces
pauvres gens l'eau vive et bien les
médiaux vous emporter ce qu'ils
voulaient bien vous apporter ou ce qu'il
pouvait bien vous emporter on a oublié
les petits gestes de tous les jours
apportez risquer sa vie pour apporter
des crayons du papier dans mon corps
lorsque je vis est particulièrement mon
petit bonheur que je mets bien me gêne
j'apportais en fait je donnais le
vendent alors à mon commandant afghan
qui lui à les acheter des sandales des
friandises ou encore crayon papier peut
pas et ça me ça me faisait du bien au
delà de pouvoir lui apporter un petit
peu de bonheur
quelle ne fut pas ma surprise en 2011
j'ai lu un article j'ai lu un article je
protestais sur internet et on racontait
que le groupement tactique du 1er
bataillon royal 22e régiment avait reçu
pour mission de protéger un équipe de
travail qui avait pour mission à faire
d'asphalté la dangereuse haute ayana
pour ceux qui ont vu le film
et lorsque les militaires se sont
approchés de mon petit village de
mougins et bien les enfants on était à
la rencontre de ces militaires pour leur
signifier pour le démontre à quel
endroit des engins explosifs avaient été
disposés à leur attention
alors mon coeur de green ch battu un
coup de plus ça me parce que c'étaient
des enfants en fait c'étaient mes
petits-enfants de mouchan que j'avais
rencontré que j'avais apporté un petit
peu de bonheur le retour au canada est
excessivement difficile parce qu'on n'a
plus sa place ni en afghanistan ni au
canada dans mon coeur moi c'est fut
encore plus difficile particulièrement
lorsque ma petite fille m'avait dit je
sais que tu es mon papa mais je me
rappelle plus de temps non
alors je voulais juste vous vous inviter
à réfléchir aujourd'hui qu'on n'a pas
besoin de risquer sa vie pour pour
reporter toutes ces petites attentions
qui apporte un peu de bonheur aux gens
qui en ont vraiment besoin
je prends pour exemple à québec qui a
désorganisé ceux qui fournissent qui
donne qui offre le petit déjeuner à des
enfants qui a incroyablement on a inclus
c'est incroyable croire aux canons à eau
ouais à québec dans la ville de québec
et des enfants qui allaient à l'école
qui ont pour but déjeuner alors il ya
des organistes ce que de fournir des
jeunes et à ses petits-enfants
alors ce sont à mon avis des organismes
sont très très lourd anges à bhl vous
aussi vous avez sûrement porter ces
petits gestes pour aider les gens qui
sont dans le besoin et je vous invite
aussi à réfléchir à qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire pour aider notre population
qui atteint souvent de nous merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]